posez lui vos questions on vous trouve
l'info jacques nous écrit quand on
commande pour emporter
de plus en plus de restaurateurs nous
demande s'ils ont redonné du pourboire
de 15-20 même grand % pour jacques c'est
un incitatif malaise ans pour les
clients une option qui apparaît de plus
en plus sur les terminaux de paiement
[Musique]
c'est vrai que les restaurateurs ont
souffert pendant la pandémie
mais est ce qu'on devrait maintenant
donner du pouvoir
même quand on commande pour remporter
[Musique]
oui bonjour madame c'est françois santé
de lille sur la facture des informations
sur les restaurants les pourboires
merci beaucoup
réponse les serveurs eux gagnent moins
que les autres employés d'un restaurant
ils s'attendent à recevoir du pouvoir
mais quand on commande pour remporter il
n'y a pas de norme comme dans le cas du
service aux tables
sentez-vous donc bien à l'aise si vous
voulez pas donné pouvoir
posez votre question on vous trouve
l'info passer le mot